you try to take on the world's richest
man you better come prepared Elon Musk
humiliating a liberal media reporter who
accused him of letting hate speech run
wild on Twitter watch
you must have at some point seen that
you for you hateful content I'm asking
for one example right I know you can't
give us and I'm saying I say so that you
don't know what you're talking about
really yes because you connect me a
single example of hateful content not
even one tweet and yet you claimed that
the hateful content was high well that's
a false no what I create a slide
Katie I think now everyone that's being
interviewed by some liberal jerk should
just turn it around on the jerk and
start asking them questions oh yeah
you've become the interviewer yes that's
the move look all these media people
walk into a room with Elon Musk thinking
they are smarter than him they are so
arrogant they do this every time and
they get rolled remember when Brian
stelter was like I hope that Elon Musk
can take over Twitter and understand
yeah moderation of content it's like
he's a rocket scientist I think he can
handle it so they do this to themselves
by having no humility and a lot of
arrogance but thinking they're smarter
yeah Seltzer can't even set the timer on
his coffee machine
aren't I right
Jessica I would prefer to use my time
doing something else besides
slam situation but he had 20 minutes
so if you have 20 minutes there's a lot
you can do on the Google machine like
anti-semitic tweets doubled from June
2022 to February 2023 Institute of
strategic dialogue okay so who funds
Institute for strategic dollars Soros
okay Melinda Gates Foundation the state
department oh wait a climate group stop
[Laughter]
and I think the other thing that drives
me crazy if you put up a picture of the
interview
it's I know we're in the age of where
you don't print things out and he's
probably the reporters are probably
younger than me but when you're using
your phone as you read like when you're
looking and you bring your phone to the
interview to read your questions off of
you gotta do better than that for me
yeah that is a great point Thank you
great Point first off I would less focus
on liberal and more like British because
there's something extra arrogant about
that that he was British but he must
revealed some really great truths one
that people who accuse others of hate
speech never think they have to bring
the evidence and then when they often
when they bring the evidence it comes
from one place that has said
regurgitated over and over again but
it's also showed you the definition of
of an entitled profession where you
don't expect to provide evidence of your
most damning smears now if you if if
these were just mild little uh uh things
you were talking about maybe you don't
bring evidence but if you're smearing
something or if you're saying you know
this causes cancer you better bring the
receipts what musk did was provide joy
to so many interview subjects who never
got this chance or lacked the skill to
do it it was just pleasurable I'd like
to say maybe I watched it seven times
it's pretty good yeah they said that uh
an example of hate speech he said
something that was slightly sexist
slightly racist slightly sexist we say
stuff that's slightly sexist all day on
this show that's your middle name
we don't I'm just kidding we never do
that no hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else